là on va jaser du concert aujourd'hui
que vous entendez ce pensez à quoi oui
eh ouais
dans cette école secondaire de
rivière-du-loup le consentement les
relations amoureuses et sexuelles font
partie des enseignements courant comme à
3 adresses pour te mettre ta limite
exemple avec tom tableau il y amène
d'année face à une augmentation des
infections transmises sexuellement et
des grossesses non désirées la santé
publique du bas saint laurent a cru bon
favoriser des initiatives pour mieux
enseigner la sexualité aux jeunes de la
région dans le sait ici que je reçois
les élèves la commission scolaire de
kamouraska rivière du loup a recruté une
sexologue à raison d'une journée par
semaine
en 2009 on a tendance à penser que les
cours d'éducation sexualité c'est de
savoir faire
puis des techniques c'est pas du tout ça
ce qui les sécurise aux autres c'est le
savoir être elle est maintenant présente
à temps plein à compter de la fin de
l'école primaire dans des ateliers en
classe ou à son bureau
ça nous apprend et bon comportement à
avoir et vu qu'on en parle on est plus
préparé ce palais parler de ton prof de
français des problèmes qui étaient si la
formation doit être donné par les
enseignants tous ici insiste sur
l'importance d'un accompagnement
spécialisé
on est l'enseignant on est là tous les
jours avec eux au cas madame cash boomer
bien c'est évident que pour les autres
c'est la spécialiste du sujet et
d'enlever la mme lalanne pression la
pression chez les enseignants les
enseignants ça reste le salut mais des
enseignants qui savent que si une
question un peu troublante qui posaient
ils peuvent référer l'élève un mois
l'établissement fait partie des 200
écoles inscrites au projet pilote du
ministre de l'éducation sébastien proulx
qui espère rendre obligatoire
l'éducation à la sexualité du primaire
au secondaire dès septembre 2018 si son
ministère entend donner des lignes
directrices aux commissions scolaires et
bien ce serait de déterminer par qui et
de quelle façon la formation sera
offerte
la formation sera ainsi différentes d'un
milieu à l'autre et si matthew zions
radio canada rivière du loup